die heute im gewand von euch demand
deutschland mein volles video
mitbekommen haben ich persönlich habe
meinen führerschein mit 17 gemacht war
meiner meinung nach eine ziemlich gute
entscheidung von viele erfahrungen
dadurch sammelt dort ganz jetzt ein
bisschen leichter ihr seht mich auch
gleich beim autofahren ansonsten vorher
oder vorweg noch wenn ihr euch auch
diesen führerschein mit 17 interessiert
wfc ist die coole seite könnt ihr euch
gerne in form eines in der video
beschreibung verlinkt und ja ich will
euch gar nicht lange vorenthalten wie
ich so jetzt alleine fahren was ich so
dabei so erlebt habe wie es mir gefällt
seht ihr jetzt viel spass
leute ich bin jetzt 18 geworden ich kann
euch auch mal schön meinen führerschein
bleibt man den namen haus von kohl habe
ich einen tag nach meinem geburtstag
bekommen
ich bin auch schon ein paar mal alleine
gefahren und ich habe gedacht kommen
nehme ich euch doch einfach mal mit
jetzt bzw
netter kumpel nimmt euch mit der der
held die kammer für mich sehr liebt dann
könnt ihr an dieser stelle und ich will
sagen wir fahren einfach mal los und mal
gucken was passiert passiert ein unfall
passiert kein unfall ich denke nein
kann man natürlich nie so sagen aber
los geht's musik machen wir aus dann
wird das video nach noch von der gema
rausgenommen
ich würde sagen ich fand einfach mal
hier aus irgendeinem industriegebiet
musste mir grade von zu hause abholen
wollte am arsch der welt
und wieder heißt es erscheint ich habe
den einen tag vor weihnachten abstand
als ich habe derzeit 9 monate 9 monate
ja natürlich wenn man den führerschein
hat am anfang oft total motiviert aber
irgendwann geht es natürlich auch um
sagt dass die eltern die ganze daneben
sitzen aber was ich dazu sagen kann
natürlich bei mir was genauso meine
eltern sind wir andauernd auf nicht für
schnell
guck mal links und rechts achtung
fußgänger
das ist natürlich ein lkw vorbei rest
muss kritisch auf jeden fall kann es zu
eins sagen wenn ihr euren führerschein
habt und eure eltern halt neben euch nur
sitzen und durch auf den sack gehen
nehmen es gelassen das ist eigentlich
ganz gute weil die natürlich auch sehr
viele fragen stellen könnt bei mir war
es oft so wenn ich an der kreuzung stand
öl was mache ich jetzt wo sich gerade
aus oder wie fahre ich jetzt links links
abbiegen ist natürlich das schwerste und
da ist es schon gut dass dann das sind
immer wir nehmen euch sitzt und ihr
fragen stellen können
zu deinen hallo hallo du hast es drauf
die schlepper und das ziemlich geil
jetzt zu fahren oder ja also als meine
erste fahrt allerdings habe das war echt
geil ich war richtig nervös auf so aber
auf jeden fall man ist halt so richtig
flexibel so dass makime com los ich will
natürlich auch als ich erfahren konnte
mit meinen eltern fahren könnte also was
ihr euch sagen kann autofahren macht
eigentlich richtig spaß nutzt es auf
jeden fall aus wenn den führerschein
hatte ich kenne auch leute die fahren
einfach nicht denken warum nicht und
fahrt weite strecken lernt ich bin auch
ganz gerne mal autobahn fahren autobahn
fahren macht auch spaß vor allem wenn
die autobahn etwas leerer ist
er kommt dass wir denken jetzt kommt ein
bulli von vorne etwas langsamer weil die
straße alter was ist mit der straße hier
los passt doch keine zwei autos
nebeneinander her oder
auf jeden fall das lustige war noch
meine eltern oder was auch wirklich
daran gut ist den führerschein mit 17 zu
machen ist das mit dem öfter mit euren
eltern fahren und wirklich gut fahrt
dann wissen wir
ihr könnt ab und fahren und das ist
nicht so dass wenn ihr meinen
führerschein erst mit 18 habe dass sie
denken dann kann noch gar nicht auto
fahren
der kriegt gar nicht unser auto war das
auto gehört auch nicht mehr wo mir jetzt
forscher aber wie gesagt auf jeden fall
wollen wir den wollen wir noch diverse
wenn man weg ist geht auf mich heute
hallo was ist zurzeit des monats bei ihm
willst du den taschen oder was anderes
ja dann zweimal den kinder ist
monatsmitte das wärs danke meine eltern
finden das jetzt nicht so gut aber die
sind ja auch zum glück nicht mehr dabei
sehe das nicht durchdringen ich mein
auto aufgezeigt mit blogger das essen
war lecker schon wieder auf dem rückweg
es gehen würde ich sagen das war's
eigentlich so weit ich habe hierzu auch
noch einen ersten teil gemacht er ist
nur eingewendet könnt ihr gerne
vorbeischauen können wir mal abkönnen
würde mich freuen
ansonsten warten weil jemand ein und
sehen wir uns dann am mittwoch wieder da
kommt wieder eine normale figur
mal gucken wie ich es sehe ganz lustig
ich würde sagen danke fürs zuschauen
danke an meinen lieben kameramann und
herr brencher